senator ted cruz along with two other
republican senators have put forward
legislation to ban the federal reserve
from creating a central bank digital
currency and issuing it directly to
individual american citizens one of the
things to know here is that they are
specifically talking about using central
bank digital currencies as surveillance
tools similar to what's happening in
china now ted cruz has been talking
about this for quite a while he's
recently become quite a big bitcoin
proponent his big concern around central
bank digital currencies is that if the
federal reserve creates them and then
issues them directly to citizens he
thinks that we'll simply increase the
surveillance capabilities without
providing a net benefit to those
individual citizens if we go ahead and
we take a look at the legislation itself
what we can see is that the bill put
forward asked to amend the federal
reserve act to prohibit the federal
reserve banks from offering certain
products or services directly to an
individual and for other purposes this
is not the only politician in america
who has thoughts around this we've had
representative tom member come on this
channel before and he had some thoughts
as well he has a tweet thread where he
talks about as other countries like
china develop cbdc's that fundamentally
omit the benefits and protections of
cash it is more important than ever to
ensure the u.s digital currency policy
protects financial privacy maintains the
dollar's dominance and cultivates
innovation he goes on to say that cbdc's
failed to adhere to three basic
principles that could enable an entity
like the federal reserve to mobilize
itself into a retail bank collect
personally identifiable information and
track their transactions indefinitely
the threat then went on to say that not
only does the cbdc model raise single
point of failure issues leaving
americans financial information
vulnerable to attack but it could be
used as a surveillance tool that
americans should never be forced to
tolerate from their own government
requiring users to open an account at
the fed to access a united states cbdc
would put the fed on an insidious path
akin to china's digital authoritarianism
pretty incredible claim and then emmer
goes on to say any cbdc implemented by
the fed must be open permissionless and
private he says that in order to
maintain the dollar status as the
world's reserve currency in a digital
age it is important that the united
states lead with the posture that
prioritizes innovation
and does not aim to compete with the
private sector and then lastly he states
that we must prioritize blockchain
technology with american characteristics
rather than mimic the nonsense going on
in china where they're simply operating
out of fear ultimately what we are
watching is politicians are waking up to
both the benefits of bitcoin but also
the concerns around central bank digital
currencies we have one shining example
of the negative side effects of the
central bank digital currencies in china
the concerns around surveillance tools
and giving more of our data to the
government are all valided they're
rooted in truth and ultimately what
we're gonna have to decide is how much
benefit how much convenience are we
willing to pursue in order to give up
some of those privacy and also
anti-surveillance methods that are in
permissionless cash transactions now
there's other schools of thought as well
we have a tweet here that goes on to
explain that banning the fed from
issuing the cbdc is the stupidest plan
politicians backed by crypto interest
ever came up with government-run digital
money is free marketing for crypto
expanding awareness and making the
latter look better in comparison expand
the pie and there's bigger opportunities
for all regardless of where you come out
on this issue one thing is for sure this
is going to be a hot topic over the next
couple of years bitcoin is the world's
most valuable digital currency and
government's one in on the game they're
going to create central bank digital
currencies and the big question is what
will be the structure how would they go
ahead and distribute this to their
citizens and what will be the impact
positive or negative in the coming
decades hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time